can you give me a timeline here how long
are you able to be on the road here
successfully three years three years
this is me this is the first few months
three years well so three years yeah
what happens is we I we get that little
chunk of money we put it deposited into
these bank accounts and we start pulling
out cash
MH um and which works out fine because
we got a bunch of accounts and we're
pulling out little amounts 7 ,000 5,000
8,000 and you know I would cash checks
against her
accounts and they would call her to
verify uh there's someone here trying to
cash a check for $99,000 you know can
you verify the pay and they go oh yeah
that's Scott cugno oh okay thank you and
they cash the check you know these are
new accounts so it looks odd but you
know we're always I open the
account so what what ends up happening
is um we're cashing them and I remember
getting really frustrated because it
just taking forever and I gone into a
bank one
time and you know they have Banks where
that they they
cash they actually cash like large
checks like if you go into Bank of
America and you try and cash a check for
$155,000 or 25,000 they probably won't
do it they'll tell you we don't have
that much cash on hand we don't this we
don't that they have certain banks that
do that so they told me where one of
those was I went there I had a check for
like
29,000 that had been cut on a closing
for Michael Shanahan remember I
refinanced Michael Shanahan's I've got a
check for 29,000 that was issued to
Scott
cugno so I'm sitting in the bank I go in
there I say I need to cash this and she
says um you're going to have to talk to
the manager I go okay she says go sit
down no over there I go sit down in the
little glass cubicle he comes over and
he says uh I see you're trying to cash
this check and I was like right he goes
why don't you just deposit in your own
bank and I went my bank account my bank
is a credit union or something and it's
in like Florida like they'll hold this
thing for like 2 weeks like I need the
money now I have people I need to pay
he's like well um I'm not sure and I was
like well it's fine it's a it's a
cashier check like it's good and he goes
no it's it's good it's good I you have
the money and he's like yeah we have the
money he said it's just odd um hold on
he goes back in the back and he comes
back and he says um where'd you get the
check cashier check I said it was a
cashier check it was drawn off of a
closing for um somebody's property that
I I we doing the company I work for
we're putting on an addition
on okay that makes sense comes back why
do you need cash I was like I I'm
cashing guys checks that work for the
company like there's a lot of these guys
that are like Mexican guys they give
them a check they go to a check cashing
company or they get charged 5 10% so I
cashed them I'm like I don't under like
what but the check's good right like my
and he's like yeah we're just trying to
verify some stuff any he went
um yeah hold on he leaves again and I
remember my cell phone rang and I pick
up the phone it's Becky what are you
doing what's taking so long I go ah the
guy's being a jerk you don't want to
give me the money well she's like oh my
God get out of the bank get out of the
bank and I I can't get out of the bank
the guy's got my ID he's got my credit
card my ID and the check for 29,000 like
he's going to call the police fight just
jump up and run MH and I go don't don't
call me again I I'll let you know it'll
be fine hang out the
phone she calls back same conversation
I'm I'm bouncing on the walls I'm like
I'm going crazy it'll be fine hang out
the phone he comes back out and he goes
uh he said um I said hey I said what's
what's taking so long and he goes um
we're trying to get in touch with uh
with Michael Shanahan to verify the
check that that's not good for me like
I'm thinking right right right okay okay
and he walks away the phone rings Becky
what's what's going on I go he's they're
trying to get a hold of Michael Shany oh
my God oh my God and I'm like oh my God
I remember thinking I should I shouldn't
let her the keys there's a good chance I
run out of this place and she does she's
not there but by the way when you're
sitting there you're who Scott you're
Scott I'm Scott cugno and then calling
Michael Shanahan right they're saying
they're trying to get in touch with
Michael Shanahan so then the phone rings
my phone cell Rings again I look and
it's not Becky's yeah not Becky so I
pick up the phone I go hello and she
says hi this is Kim is it from Sun Trust
Bank is this Michael
Shanahan so I'm like yes it is Michael
Shanahan and she says there's a guy here
he's trying to cash a check it's very
large could you verify the pay and I go
sure it's Scott cugno he's trying I said
I believe the amount is $29,000 and she
goes that's right thank you very much I
appreciate it I said okay said hey by
the way how'd you get my number this is
my cell number and she's like oh I'm
sorry we called the title
company and the title company gave us
your phone number well I closed those
loans that's my sale that's why if they
looked in any other way I would have
they could have gotten in touch with a
real Michael
Shanahan so I was like oh okay hang up
the phone you're sitting you answered
the phone from the bank while sitting in
the bank as as as
as Scott pretending to be M so I right
so I just verified the check myself as
Matthew pretending to be Scott is
pretending to be Michael right yeah
so I wait there terrified still they
come out about two minutes later the
manager comes out plus a woman I'm
assuming maybe it was Kim she never said
anything and she walks out and she says
and and he counts out the money twice
29,000 29,000 and I stand up and I mean
just like I'm like shoving the money in
my pockets like I'm trying to get out of
there so quick I'm like hey I'm like
okay cool um like I'm thinking this
whole thing is is you know feels bad and
I'm getting up and I'm so
I'm I'm starting to walk out of the bank
and he
goes he said um excuse me Mr cugno and I
said yes sir I turn around and he goes
I'd like you know like you to know that
I feel very apprehensive about this
transaction I go really what is it
exactly he goes I I can't put my finger
on it and I go it'll come to you and I
turn around I just bolt right out of
there and so keep in mind a week or so
later the Secret Service shows up MH did
you cash a check for
$29,000
so um what's so funny is like that was
one of the last checks we cashed so we
ended up with like 400,000 was there a
connection between the Secret Service
and this guy no the apprehension so the
FBI is looking for me kind of in in
Tampa yeah and they've put out a a
fugitive warrant for me which which is
how the US Marshals got involved so US
Marshals track down fugitives Yes
Federal Fugitives they track
down but everybody's after you you're on
every list right I'm on the FBI's list
at that point the Secret Service got
involved once I leave Atlanta so when
Becky and I pack up our bags and we
leave
Atlanta the Secret Service got involved
because of identity
theft um you know banking identity that
the Secret Service doesn't just do
counterfeiting and protect the president
they also protect the financial
infrastructure of the United States and
they especially have jurisdiction when
identity theft is involved so identity
theft plus bank fraud they're that's
when they they move yeah that's it
that's their their um their territory so
Marshals are just fugitives US Marshall
is just fugitives they don't do any
inves they're all kind of work okay but
they're all kind of working together
yeah yeah the the you know like the US
Marshals are like let's say an arm of
all of the various law enforcement
agencies federal agencies not the states
the states have their own fugitive task
forces or fugitive so when you leave
Atlanta basically everybody's after you
everybody's after me did you know this
at that time or did you sense it or no I
mean now you know world every day you're
looking up you're looking your name up
every day like I'm not because I'm just
trying to get a bunch of money and and
just blend in right things were not as
interconnected at that time as they are
now yeah but they're starting to get
interconnected but of course I have no
idea how much I I barely go on the
internet for anything you know dating
that's the only thing the internet you
know I'd never been on Facebook at this
point now Facebook isn't even even out
yet this is
2006 still were you trying to stay low
yeah I I am I'm not a flashy person like
I'm not driving you know like I didn't
go out and buy a a a red Lamborghini you
know I'm driving I'm driving4 $50,000
cars you know I've had some sports cars
7080 you know maybe that's $150,000
sports car now but it's still not flashy
it's not like it's bright red or yellow
I me these are it's always something you
know nondescript and I'm living in areas
that these cars are
everywhere
that